well Russ let's start with HSBC one of
the biggest gainers today on the footsie
100 so headline profits down underlying
profits that market like what they heard
I think it did because mending is the
fourth quarter numbers have been such an
absolute mess that was actually relief
to get a relatively straightforward set
of figures and if you looked
retail banking investment banking and
commercial banking all showed
year-on-year improvement in operating
profit I think that was what the market
really latched on to the tricky bit is
there was still some one-off items in
there that did make the numbers
difficult to interpret another couple
hundred million pounds of the PPI
provisions for example so they're not
out of the woods there yet but
nevertheless the numbers Doolin's
beginning a little bit clean a little
bit more straightforward and that was
some underlying growth there which I
guess was the major relief yeah you sure
seems to come back quite nicely yeah I
think that's the big thing when over I
mean obviously the numbers were a little
bit you sorted by the sale of the
Brazilian operation so they've washed
their hands of that one the bank of
Raleigh's still shrinking its way back
to health
assets are still falling and loans and
deposits are still slightly down
year-on-year
so long run I think in the short term
you've got cost is a big story age is a
big story long it's where's the real
growth coming from given its been
spending so much time shrinking itself
and it still got the regulator on his
back as well another it's a big year for
this Bank because of course they've got
a new Chairman coming in and more Tucker
we expect you're Gulliver the CEO
travels and this year yes but we still
haven't had confirmation of that from
the bank ever no not at all no mr.
Gulliver's dropped some very heavy hints
that five six seven years is quite
enough thank you very much but there's
been no confirmation yet I think they
wanted to get the Chairman in place
first and then mr. Tucker can clearly
put in place a very clear succession
plan now in terms of the horror shows
that we saw today next was probably the
biggest one I mean biggest I mean last
month in out so first drop in profits it
so nine and today profits warning yeah
again a lord Wolfson sort of refined
their profit guidance for the year sales
now expected to drop one and a half
percent rather than half a percent he
shared about three to five percent of
their profits forecast it just looks to
be a very very tough market out then
don't forget next is one of these
companies it's actually trying to
increase prices which in a fast-fashion
market that's very price conscious
really isn't terribly easy to do and I
think that's one of the things that's
probably causing them some pain at the
moment what was really shocking about it
so Russell and it was the fact that shop
sales were down 8% so
line is washing its face people just not
going in the store it's the gold clicks
versus brick story that we've heard so
much in the retail environment overall
we saw a fantastic numbers from Peugeot
and their source recently it's clearly
taking its toll on the high street next
does have a very strong online presence
but I'm not sure it's websites quite as
slick as some of the competitors out
there and that is definitely causing the
company some trouble and if I can Alissa
now expecting profit to drop last well
they did drop last year now this year
and indeed the year after as well now so
no easy fixes for next not at the moment
obviously we wonderful if the economy
was to start firing on all cylinders but
consumer debt including mortgages is
already the record high so it's hard to
see how much room for maneuver is there
the one thing that probably would make
the life easier is if the pound starts
going up now they may not be holding
their breath but that was certainly
helped them in terms of raw material
costs it would help consumers in terms
of less inflation and it means the
company wouldn't maybe have to start
popping prices up by four or five
percent which perhaps are finding quite
difficult at the moment another the big
boys of the market Royal Dutch Shell I
mean again market really liked what they
heard today clearly they've been boosted
by the lift up in oil prices but the BG
acquisition last year looks to be paying
off yeah there was lot of doubts at the
time I must admit I was a little bit
skeptical myself so I'm eating a few
words I mean the oil price up 55% year
in the air and average in the first
quarter is of a massive plus for them
the exploration production business went
back into profit refining made a higher
profit but the company is helping itself
production volumes are up - and costs
were down eight and I think that's a lot
of the BG costs being ripped out and
that's where the company is working
particularly hard and best of all I
think cash flow was very strong it more
than covered the dividend which makes a
nice change and for an investor's point
of view that's the real core to the
stock I think anybody is expecting the
underlying production growth to go
through the ceiling but if that 7%
dividend yield is safe a lot of income
hunters will will hug it to their chest
very very close let's yes yama is worth
remembering one pound in every eight
worth of dividends received by UK
pension funds comes from this cut its
enormous but we must remember as well
you mentioned already the oil price has
been very volatile in the past music
started to go down again which isn't
which obviously isn't going to be helped
and I think the finance director today
said that one dollar on oil is about
five hundred million dollars on profits
for the company so it's still very very
sensitive to the to the price of crude
yeah so barrel Brent went below fifty
bucks a barrel today for the first time
since November of
I think there's some nerves out of the
OPEC meeting in Vienna on the 25th will
they stick to the production cuts that
they pushed through last November you've
seen you American inventory stockpiles
of raw crude and refined gasoline that
stubbornly refused to come down in
Oklahoma could Cushing Oklahoma route
and are still at very high levels and us
rig activity you can track it every week
from Baker Hughes has gone through the
roof it's more than doubled from its
lows last year so soon as its oil hits
around $50 those shale drillers in the
States
fire up the rigs again and start pumping
out crude so you still do look to be
looking at a bit of an over supplied
market ultimately yeah there you go
there's a price at the moment well there
we are a 48 barrel down four and a half
percent wolf and briefly we have
Morrison's as well sixth consecutive
quarter of life which is which the
market like very much a 3% increase from
the retail business I think three and a
half percent overall boss David Potts
does look to be doing a very good job I
mean he talks about some of that fresh
product ranges going rather well
womenswear we actually find interesting
has been everywhere they've been
particularly aggressive Marks and
Spencers next shareholders probably a
little bit less enthused about that it
may be an additional complication for
them but again expectations have been
low for this company it put through its
first profit increase last year for four
or five years in big contracts to next
but equally now the market is looking
for profit increases this year and next
year as well so momentum does look to be
building more of a self-help story than
overall market stories as a challenge so
now as Nyx's growth or growth that's the
thing in OC if you look at the Kantar
Worldpanel numbers yesterday from the
consultants Morrison's Tesco's
Sainsbury's still lost market share of
year-over-year to Aldi and Lidl and
those discounters it is still a very
very tough market the company isn't
going to be resting on its laurels I
suspect all right Russ molds very
comprehensive come to through the
numbers register that's all